Questa è una di quelle storie uno di
quei buchi in cui cadi mentre stai
cercando qualcosa e finisci per trovare
tutt'altro è più scavi a mani nude e più
Vai a fondo e più Vai a fondo e più fai
riemergere cose sopite che forse era
meglio lasciare lì sotto tre metri di
terriccio voglio raccontarvi la storia
di questo kolossal l'italiano
cinematografico sparito nel nulla
[Musica]
Tutto è iniziato come ogni storia che si
rispetti Quando in una noiosissima
giornata di settembre mi arriva una mail
sono un Visual Effect Artist che lavora
a film internazionale il sunto è ho
lavorato agli effetti visivi di questo
film di fantascienza italiano e poi non
se n'è più saputo nulla e mi metto
subito al lavoro per cercare più
informazioni possibili O almeno tutto
quello che riesco a trovare online il
film è creators the Past questa
produzione italiana di fantascienza che
già quella è una cosa incredibile che
non si trova da nessuna parte ma non
perché sia molto raro proprio perché non
esiste nessuna distribuzione né fisica
né in streaming il regista è Pier
Giuseppe Zaia e nel suo curriculum
possiamo trovare solo creators the Past
Sì questo film di fantascienza è
un'opera prima è come se Spielberg senza
saper toccare una telecamera Non facesse
come primo film Salvate il soldato Ryan
Lo troveremo ancora lì sulla spiaggia in
Normandia per favore aiutatemi qui
possiamo trovare il signor Zaia in
compagnia di Corrado al terzo festival
della città di Novara macarim perché ci
stai facendo vedere questa vecchissima
foto di Zaia da bambino palesemente
presa dal suo archivio di Facebook
perché non è presa dall'archivio di
Facebook ma è una foto del suo profilo
IMDb ci sono 77 foto prese nei momenti
più disparati della sua vita mancano
soltanto le vacanze a Belluno
probabilmente abbiamo finito l'album lui
da piccolo si può trovare in queste
situazioni perché cantava tanto che
anche inciso un vinile con le canzoni
bambina canta Anche tu e dici o no
Champions No ancora no queste
informazioni sono zero utili ai fini
della storia del film ma volevo comunque
dirvelo perché le ho imparate e mi
dispiaceva tenerle nel magazzino del
cervello poi prendono polvere ed è un
dispiacere e tra l'altro ho trovato quel
mettere in vendita su discog a 40 euro
mortacci del film giusto appunto si può
trovare online il trailer
il nucleo
della vita così a sentimento è un
lungometraggio che io vorrei guardare in
questo momento e non so se sia una cosa
buona o no se lo dico io
e non avete delle fette di salame sugli
occhi quelli che avete visto sono
proprio William Shatner Gerard Depardieu
e Bruce Pain e il fatto che ci sia
William Shatner viene scritto ovunque in
qualsiasi articolo in qualsiasi
anteprima che si cerca online viene
detto che c'è Oh mio Dio William Shatner
e a me fa molto ridere non tanto perché
ci sia William Shatner Ma perché ci sia
il William Shatner di adesso che se ha
detto sì a creators the Past Ma anche sì
a devolves Revenge
non so quanto Beh però è comunque
William Shatner che comunque tra Shatner
e Pain Depardieu rosico nel non poterlo
guardare ma non essendo stato
distribuito da nessuna parte da qui come
ci si muove ed infatti è successa una
cosa molto strana cercando online questo
film
scavando io ho trovato di tutto di
creators the Past ho trovato anteprime
ho trovato recensioni ho trovato un
sacco di interviste di Pier Giuseppe
Zaia e la scrittrice del film e anche
del libro da cui è tratto creators
Eleonora Fanni tanto tempo e tante
persone per poter realizzare quello che
dicono che sia il più grande colloson
mai creato in Italia per il mondo c'è
stata la proiezione in anteprima a Lucca
Comics 2019 con tutta la sala piena Nel
2020 è uscito il film nelle sale
italiane in moltissime città d'Italia
con tanto di regista e scene che
andavano a fare le proiezioni in
anteprima andavano a fare le interviste
ed è una sensazione stranissima poter
trovare qualsiasi
qualsiasi tipo di informazione su un
film che tu non potrai mai guardare E
come tutte le fotografie dei Bigfoot è
pieno zeppo di fotografie Se le cerchi
ma non c'è il Bigfoot ma diamo un paio
di numeri nel canale ufficiale di
creators the Past Dove si può trovare il
trailer si può trovare qualche piccola
anteprima il primissimo video caricato è
di Gérard Depardieu che invita la gente
a guardare il creators
otto anni fa Ma se noi diamo per buona
l'uscita nelle sale del 2020 come è
possibile che il video di Gérard
depardio sia di 8 anni fa perché questo
lungometraggio è stato una produzione
lunghissima di 5 anni e a quanto dice
Andrea costata 10 milioni di euro e da
quanto si trova online quindi prendiamo
queste cifre con le pinze Ne ha
guadagnati poco più di 100.000 ahi ahi
ahi a ramba Però però però però però
però il film come
non lo possiamo dire non lo possiamo
vedere quindi noi non possiamo dare
un'opinione noi ma tutti gli altri
recensori sia su YouTube sia al di fuori
sì è il responso
non è dei migliori Ma personalmente non
vorrei vedere nulla altro di questa Saga
Anzi mi domando quanto budget abbia
avuto E da chi il primo commento che ho
letto non articolo commento sotto un
video che parlava di come fosse il film
l'ho trovato proprio sotto una video
intervista di una delle attrici di
creators Jennifer mischiati Jennifer sei
l'unica presenza piacevole ma per il
resto 100% pessimo al di là di Chat Noir
che è un po' scoppiato è subito sotto o
appena finito di vedere questo film al
cinema spendendo ben 10 euro e 90 posso
dire che la più grande merdata mai vista
Vabbè che saranno mai due commenti
negativi su tre da lì parte una
diramazione di recensioni tra
giornalisti e youtuber che l'hanno visto
chi al cinema chi ha quella famosa
anteprima di Lucca nel 2019 Io non so
più cosa dire veramente un film
Totalmente folle nel senso più sbagliato
del termine stupido sconclusionato
inconcludente anche nell'ottica del
primo capitolo di una trilogia a prezzo
più o meno il tentativo del regista ma
probabilmente un po' di umiltà e la
visione ripetuta di altri film italiani
che davvero hanno saputo distinguersi
negli ultimi anni sarebbero state
necessarie ed avendo questo mulo
invalicabile davanti a me del non poter
vedere il film in nessun modo ho pensato
di fare L'unica cosa che potessi fare in
quel momento scrivere al ragazzo e
parlare con qualcuno che ha lavorato al
film e gentilmente hanno accettato
Andrea e Marco due ragazzi che hanno
lavorato agli effetti visivi del film Ne
ho mangiati una pizza eh siamo guardate
negli occhi abbiamo detto Ragazzi ma che
cazzo abbiamo lavorato è stato
proiettato in certe sale molte persone
l'hanno visto hanno avuto la fortuna per
adesso gli uniche persone al mondo che
hanno visto queste feste sono state
tante tante Diciamo tanti step non
canonici all'interno di questa
produzione ci sono tutte delle scene che
sono già delle carnevale vivere a quelle
arancio No ma la cosa bella mi ricordo
che praticamente non gli piacevano
queste scene quindi due cose Ogni anno
carnevale di Ivrea per rigirare la
stessa scena per vedere se era venuta
meglio ma è incredibile Questa cosa ci
mancava una scena di spalle che in
montaggio non funzionava e ci mancava
solo un controcampo di spalle di
Depardieu e ho preso un amico del
regista che era un panettiere Uguale
uguale È una fatti i capelli simili ce
l'ho fatta e viene se ne sei accorto di
noi ma ti prego bellissimo cosa si
percepiva trattori Insomma tutto tutta
la troupe sempre stato fatto tutto con
abbastanza molto rispetto soprattutto
quando un attore l'attore quando
arrivava dall'estero in produzione
faceva il giro negli studi eccetera era
estremamente incuriosito partendo da
prima esperienza entrambi adesso siamo
generalista e composito in Industrial
Light & Maggie comunque non c'era una
produzione continua Come può essere
delle grandi compagnie quindi era una
cosa la Boris gigante Però divertente
bella Cioè nel senso
molto addirittura la conversazione è
durata una buona ora ma un consulto è
che almeno a livello di produzione
proprio L'ambiente lavorativo era molto
molto positivo e io non credo che potrò
mai ringraziarli abbastanza per questa
piccola intervista e tra l'altro Grazie
a loro sono riuscito ad avvicinarmi
parallelamente a Pier Giuseppe Zaia non
ho potuto intervistarlo anche se avrei
voluto perché avrei voluto fargli un
sacco di domande
chiedergli spiegazioni e soprattutto
qualche info sul futuro della
distribuzione di creators the Past Ma
anche se ha risposto Non ha voluto
rilasciare nessun tipo di dichiarazione
ufficiale sarebbe dovuto finire qui e il
senso del video sarebbe dovuto essere
ricordatevelo Quando uscirà creators in
streaming o in DVD Ricordatevi grazie a
questo video non fatelo morire invano Ma
come ci ricorda Pablo Trincia nel
podcast veleno
C'è sempre un lato A e un lato B di ogni
storia lato umano e lato B dato a lato
[Musica]
B
sotto la recensione di creators the Past
di nerd evil.it di cui abbiamo letto un
estratto Poco fa ci sono un paio di
commenti uno di questi è un commento che
io ho letto quasi subito all'inizio
della ricerca perché questa è una delle
prime recensioni che ho letto è quello è
uno dei primi commenti al film a cui io
non ho dato tanto peso o almeno non
subito Ci ho messo quasi un mese per
pensare a quello che Alberto ha scritto
e poi ritirarlo fuori per questo lato B
e vorrei fare la stessa cosa con voi vi
parlo subito di questo commento ma lo
tirerò fuori soltanto alla fine dopo
aver letto tutto quello che potevo
leggere su piergiuseppe Zaia sono
passato agli altri interpreti del film e
c'è un nome che spicca più di tutti gli
altri e Leonora Fanny
a tutti gli appassionati di fantascienza
Ci siamo quasi lei è sceneggiatrice del
film attrice lei ha anche scritto il
libro da cui è tratto il film è quello
volendo si trova si può leggere anche su
Amazon in formato kindle Eleonora Fanni
vi aspetta al cinema Tra l'altro ho
avuto un po' di difficoltà con Eleonora
Fani a capire chi interpretasse nel film
perché io non avendolo visto mi baso
Soltanto sulle presentazioni del
personaggi che trovo online e lei non la
trovavo da nessuna parte poi l'ho
trovata lei interpreta un personaggio
nero che in teoria dovrebbe essere un
alieno Anche perché appunto lei non lo è
certo non aiuta il fatto che lei alla
famosa presentazione del film a Lucca
Comics 2019 si sia presentata in costume
circondata da bambini che volevano
l'autografo del personaggio ma
spostandoci da questo campo minato la
prima cosa che si trova su Google della
fame e il suo canale YouTube e a primo
impatto sono rimasto un po' stordito
diciamo perché mi era familiare questo
tipo di impostazione di anteprime di
sottotitoli la Matrix oltre la Matrix
manipolazione del dissenso terza guerra
mondiale
hybris declino e morte del Deep state
sembrerebbe apparentemente la versione
Light di Adam Kadmon o uno prova
scostarselo alla fine si torna sempre lì
ed esattamente come Adam sul suo Canale
si trova un po' di tutto È un film Il
primo di una trilogia Fantasy di
fantascienza Più che altro sto pensando
di fare nove sessioni nove parti e
questa è la numero uno che cazzo sto
guardando pure il banner mi ricorda lui
ma basta Esci dalla mia testa
esattamente come il commento che abbiamo
messo da parte durante questo mese ci
sono stati vari tasselli che sembravano
far parte di un puzzle diverso da quello
che stavo cercando io ma piano piano
hanno iniziato ad amalgamarsi in questa
palla di
delirio che sto presentando la pagina
Facebook questa pagina è piena di
piccole cose interessanti interviste
articoli di giornale foto dal set
piccoli backstage e la locandina di
quella che Sembrerebbe essere un
intervento in un The Space chiamato
divinità creatori extraterrestri dalla
storia alle leggende dalla realtà al
mito interverrà Eleonora Fanni ma non
vuol dire nulla anche perché io non ho
toccato la trama di creators perché
appunto non avendolo visto non volevo
farlo ma ora sono un po' costretto
perché potrebbe contestualizzare queste
cose che vedo ci sono nell'universo 8
Day 8 membri di un consiglio galattico
se non l'ho capito male Ognuno di questi
dei crea e governa il proprio pianeta
tutto questo tramite una sfera ve la
faccio semplice Uno di questi dei perde
la sfera e c'è il rischio che gli umani
Scoprono che ci sono questi otto che
hanno creato l'universo Quindi ci sta
che la creatrice di questa storia faccia
parte di una conferenza di divinità
creatori extraterrestre e sapere a
grandi linee la trama è un punto di
svolta per quello che vi sto per dire
sotto i commenti del trailer di creators
alcuni incuriositi dal film che sarebbe
dovuto uscire due anni fa altri un po'
più scettici e altri ancora strani come
questo commento qui il più bel film che
abbia mai visto basato oltretutto su
storia vera e una fortuna che non
l'abbiano fatto sparire
tralasciando il finale che più
inquietante di così non si può visto che
il film effettivamente non si trova più
basato oltretutto su storia vera poco
più sotto un film che dà fastidio a
molti credenti È giustamente c'è uno che
dice sarebbe strano e fantascienza
ancora sotto storia molto affascinante
Chissà se contiene qualche verità
discussione sotto il commento Pensavo
fosse un fake il progetto Blue bim però
dopo aver visto Obama a parlare di UFO
poco più sotto la verità in un film Oh
no io come come posso affrontare questo
argomento
nella mia vita in generale Come posso
affrontare questo argomento perché c'è
tutta questa gente presa bene dal fatto
che sia una storia vera
creators the Past Perché i misteri
dell'universo sono una delle cose che mi
affascina di più ma finché sono teorie
io non mi sbilancerei né da una parte Né
dall'altra capito con questo tipo di
teorie e molta gente esulta perché nel
2020 non si sapeva ancora che sarebbe
sparito nel nulla questo film Ma la
gente Era contenta che uscisse creators
mica come annunaki il film che è stato
cancellato dalle lobby dei poteri forti
non sapete che cos'è annunaki Ma dai
hanno anche quella pellicola boicottata
da tutte tutti una pellicola misteriosa
che sarebbe stata composta da il
documentario mai usciti si parlò di una
censura ai danni del regista e del cast
e della scomparsa da internet di tutto
ciò che riguardava a lungometraggio la
trama sul pianeta Nibiru Il dodicesimo
del sistema solare loro inizia a
scarseggiare e l'atmosfera diventa
respirabile alla Lou re degli Anunnaki
spodestato dal nuovo realu sfugge con il
proprio carro Celeste per non incorrere
all'esilio e questo è uno dei tre film
documentari e quindi se vi ricordate
quel commento che abbiamo messo da parte
che io ho letto all'inizio di questa
ricerca e non capivo cosa volesse dire
adesso ha tutto senso Alberto aveva
teorizzato con il suo commento e leggo
Testualmente che il film abbia attirato
intorno a sé uno strano gruppo di
complottisti quelli che credono nella
colonizzazione aliena nel calendario
maya nelle teorie degli antichi
astronauti e nei poteri forti al
servizio degli alieni che controllano il
mondo e porca di una [ __ ] aveva
ragione E io non avevo capito un mese fa
perché avesse ragione e c'è un altro
nome oltre Eleonora Fani che appare
molto spesso sotto i commenti e ogni
tanto anche negli articoli che è questo
personaggio che interpreta se stesso nel
film chiamato Mauro Biglino io nella mia
ignoranza non sapevo chi fosse il signor
Biglino E allora sono andato a leggere
la pagina di Wikipedia Mauro Biglino è
uno scrittore italiano che sostiene
divulga le proprie teorie personali in
merito alla traduzione della Bibbia alla
storia delle religioni e all'origine
dell'uomo non riconosciute dalla
comunità scientifica e legate agli
ambiti pseudoscientifici della pseudo
storia dell'ufologia e in particolare
della cosiddetta teoria degli antichi
astronauti perché perché
finisce sempre così Ogni storia come
come degenerato tutto Come siamo finiti
Alla pseudoscienza da un film sparito
era un semplice video su un film sparito
come cazzo siamo finiti su Nibiru e
sulla teoria degli antichi astronauti Ma
cosa succede e sai cosa ti dico sai cosa
cazzo ti dico che io sono pronto Quando
creators the Past uscirà in Italia sarò
pronto
[Musica]
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
pa pa
[Musica]
se vuoi Proteggere le tue password ed
evitare che i poteri forti te le Rubino
Nord VPN arriva in tuo aiuto quando il
cappello di carta stagnola non basta
Nord VPN cripta i dati dalle connessioni
pubbliche in modo da evitare di farti
rubare tutto quanto e ti permette di
connetterti ADP del paese diverso da
quello in cui sei residente loro non ce
lo dicono la verità è là fuori
eccetera Se volete provare nuovi VPN
Potete utilizzare il codice sconto
Yotobi Porca [ __ ]